[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with susie boniface
and jake wallace simons they'll be with
us from now until just before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the guardian says households are being
warned the golden era of cheap food is
over as figures show two in five people
are buying less food to get by
while the express leads with the prime
minister scrapping plans to ban
two-for-one deals on unhealthy foods in
a bid to help struggling families with
the rising cost of living
boris johnson is demanding millions of
people who work from home need to get
back to the office to lift productivity
and revive town and city centres that's
according to the mail
cabinet minister jacob rees-mogg has
told the daily telegraph he thinks civil
servants are working from home on
mondays and fridays so they can have a
long weekend
the mirror goes with colleen rooney
giving evidence at the so-called wag the
christie libel trial at the high court
with her revealing she and wayne rooney
broke up in 2017.
education secretary nadine zahawi has
told the times that britain should be
very proud of its private schools and
not tilt the system to ensure more
pupils from state schools are admitted
to oxbridge
ft weekend leads with the news that elon
musk is putting his twitter takeover
temporarily on hold over concerns about
the number of spam and fake accounts on
the platform
prince william has personally given
bowel cancer awareness champion deborah
james her damehood at her parents home
in surrey that's on the front of the sun
the daily star reports on former tory mp
neil parish who was caught watching
pornography in the house of commons
saying he may stand for re-election
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by suzy
boniface and jake wallace simons welcome
to you both let's start with the
guardian and their headline golden era
of cheap food is over households are
told uh this is um
instigated we're told by the prime
minister take us into this one susie
well the the first part of the story is
about a former sainsbury's boss chap
called justin king who says that he
thinks food is going to be more
expensive in the long term it's not just
a brexit thing or a covey thing or a or
a war in ukraine thing um he says
there's been a golden era of cheap food
uh and that's this is now going to you
know have to change permanently and um
there'll be a higher proportion of
household budgets spent on food in the
longer term he says
and at the same time um boris johnson's
one of his uh decisions uh discussions
in cabinet about trying to alleviate the
cost of living crisis rather than impose
a windfall tax or uh you know cut v80 on
fuel which would be one of the many
benefits of brexit we could have had um
he's in fact saying that he's going to
delay banning bog offs so you will still
be able to get bog offs he's not going
to outlaw them uh until for another year
so you have another year of bog offs if
anybody feels like doing it but of
course that just in case people don't
know what bogots are buy one get one
free i buy one get one free i'm sure
skyview isn't exactly what they are but
you're still going to be able to get
those if anybody wants them but of
course that means that you've got to
have enough money to buy the food in the
first place uh and then somewhere to
store two lots of it so it doesn't
benefit everybody but that's boris
johnson's big idea to ease the cost of
living crisis you can still have block
offs but but boris johnson according to
to the newspaper this article is
understood to have decided to postpone
uh the implementation of the policy so
it's not uh completely taken off the
agenda jake
that's right so i suppose um you know uh
any kind of reduction in red tape uh is
is welcome but the government could be
doing a lot more uh as i think most
people feel in the country uh to help to
ease the cost of living crisis we're
facing a position where
people on on very low wages pensioners
and so on um are seeing their bills rise
uh above their disposable income and
that is pushing people into poverty and
the government does seem to be rather on
the back foot in terms of responding to
this uh labor has suggested again and
again this windfall tax on the oil
companies um and that would help but
only perhaps temporarily and it's not a
very tory solution but there are lots of
tourist solutions that the stories
aren't going for uh you know we've got a
record almost a record high of a tax
burden uh which is not a conservative
thing to do and that could be cut back
you know as as susan that the vat could
be held back that was supposed to be a
temporary increase it's turned into a
permanent one that could be cut back uh
national insurance hike could have been
reversed that didn't need to happen um
and other taxes as well corporation tax
and even income tax you know they need
to be
acting like tory's allowing people to
keep more of their money to help them
get through uh this cost living crisis
and boost the economy at the same time
that's what tories are supposed to be
doing at the moment unfortunately boris
isn't governing like one uh it has to be
said though that rishi sunak isn't
ruling out um
tax cuts or even a windfall tax it's
it's something that he says uh is in the
frame and he's thinking about but moving
on to the express and with this uh
well roll back on uh buy one get one
free that said that the prime minister
is only
affecting this because of pressure from
from tory mps susie
yeah he's obviously under a lot of
pressure from his back benches to
actually do something about the cost of
living crisis but the the real
calculation here and there's some other
papers tonight that i sort of got some
analysis of this as well is that the
the problem is between number 10 and
number 11 downing street so the prime
minister and wishy sunak are just as
much at loggerheads as gordon brown and
tony blair used to be and they probably
get on slightly less well especially
since they've had to share some criminal
penalties for parties um but what's
happening is they're trying to discuss
whether you would a moment according to
the analysis they're trying to discuss
whether it's a
low income tax cut income tax or slash
vat on a few things and the problem with
that is that if you lower income tax
that benefits the middle classes but
doesn't really help the people at the
bottom who are suffering the most
and if you slash vat it does help those
people but according to this analysis
and i quote you don't get the political
capital so what they want is they want
the credit they want the political boost
of cutting something and making people
richer they don't just want to make
people less poor they want to get their
credit for it as well and they need to
help their voters their base which is
the middle classes
while at the same time being seen to
help people who are at the poorer end of
society and you can't do all those
things you can't square that circle so
that's the argument they're having and
it seems to be that rishi sunang doesn't
want to turn the taps on doesn't want to
spend and boris johnson does and they're
both in need of some good news and
neither of them really quite know how to
find it which is
sub-optimal
uh jake how do you think they are going
to arrive at the good news as susie
suggests
well i do think as i've said that an
overhaul of of government policy needs
to take place with regard to taxation uh
at the moment as susie mentioned it does
feel as if the policies are unfair for
example the national insurance hike
is designed to help people not to have
to sell their homes or home owners not
to have to sell their homes to fund
their care when they get older so that's
to help people who've got money to keep
more of it
at the same time the tax burden being
increased in this way is harming is most
harming people at the very lowest end of
the socio-economic spectrum so these are
messages these are not messages which
win elections and we've got one coming
up in a couple of years
and the government really needs to get
groups of this cost of christ across a
living crisis
or else i fear it may get a hammer at
the ballot box
susie is the eu trying to punish britain
after brexit as uh jacob rees-mogg
suggests
they're being very clever attic because
they're using the brexit deal that jacob
rees-mogg and his government voted for
and negotiated and thought was brilliant
not long ago
so um what that what's happened is that
oh god we're back in 2019 again i
thought we'd got out of here once
already but we seem to keep getting
sucked back in like al pacino trying to
get out of
mafia crime gangs
um so what's happened is that uh because
of
the the fundamental
dilemma of brexit which is that we
needed to control
one land border we have with the eu and
it was one that we're not allowed to
control
um so the dup which
wants that border controlled and doesn't
want a border in the irc has pulled out
of any kind of power sharing deal in
northern ireland
that also means now that they want and
liz truss is threatening to tear up the
northern ireland protocol which is the
agreement with the eu that we won't
control that border but there will be
some checks on goods coming across the
rsc from mainland britain
the dup hate that because it separates
them from the rest of the uk
and what we had before all this before
the protocol we had the backstop which
sort of fixed some of these problems but
then boris johnson his government didn't
like that nor did the dep so that got
binned we've been the backstop then we
got the protocol which lord frost
uh david frost actually negotiated he
won a peerage for negotiating it and now
he's saying today as well it's no good
we have to scrap it um who knows what's
going to happen but the dup doesn't seem
to have much of a clue and nor does liz
trust but uh it seems like there's
threats of trade wars and eu and uh the
uk having a big fight about things and
of course meanwhile the situation in
northern ireland means that there is no
there's a power vacuum they're not
sharing power uh and that's not good
news yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
to the northern ireland assembly by the
dp and just very quickly uh jake we head
to the times boris johnson uh planning
crisis talks in northern ireland
yes i i think i i may have heard wrong
but i think susie just referred to the
eu as a mafia crime gang uh certainly i
think from the government's point of
view
that's brexit there's a massive crime
guy
certainly from the government's uh point
of view um that's how it feels because
um we face a really serious situation in
northern ireland you know that the the
good friday agreement is absolutely key
to peace on the island of ireland and
that's what's under threat as a result
of the dup not join the executive
because of concerns about the eu's
implementation of the northern ireland
protocol
and there is a provision in article 16
of the protocol which says that if um
you know everyday life and uh stability
of any of the countries involved is
affected by the protocol
then there is permission to to cancel
parts of it and i think the government
really has been left with no choice but
to implement that if it wants to protect
the good friday agreement and peace in
ireland this is a very it's a serious
matter and it deserves serious
consideration it's not one for chess
beating it's not one for posturing it's
something that has to be sorted out and
the good friday agreement really must be
our priority
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me the daily mirror
economist susie boniface and the editor
of the jewish chronicle jake wallace
simons let us uh dive into the times
front page there
and who is telling us to be proud of
private education jake
well this is the uh education secretary
himself museums of harwi who
is responding to a bit of a row uh over
oxford and cambridge um there was uh
like an idea from a
from within cambridge that
privately educated uh students
prospective students would begin to see
their premium as it were fall
so
they would begin to be discriminated
against in favor of um of state school
educated children who would
gain more places at oxford at the
expense of public school uh children
now um
nadine's army is lashing out against
this and saying that we shouldn't be
ashamed of public schools their their
standards are very very high we should
be proud of them now personally i'm i'm
no particular fan of public schools
particularly as they get i mean they're
you know they're wonderful the standards
are very high but they're you know fewer
and fewer people each year can afford to
actually send their children to them and
instead they seem to be businesses run
largely on attracting foreign students
to pay exorbitant sums um to as
businesses basically um but i do feel
that looking from the other point of
view from oxford and cambridge's point
of view i think they should be purely
meritocratic i think that we need to
have a university system in which the
best students get places regardless of
their class background
or the education they've received
otherwise the standards of our
universities will go down we'll hollow
out our universities from within and
before we know it we won't have
universities that are competing on the
world stage adequately and we won't
really have universities that are
educating our young people properly to
compete internationally so that really
is my main concern with this susie do
you believe that privately educated
students are being discriminated against
or that university entry is on merit if
you don't get the grades you don't get
in
i find it astonishing that jake used the
word discrimination uh about anyone
who's going to a private school because
they are by definition having a having
us her hand up a step up they're not
being discriminated against and if you
know it's how universities uh and other
schools set their um set their entry
requirements if they set their entry
requirements to be based on merit and to
be based on scores and marks that you
get then the ones who do best are going
to be getting in and i think that um the
education secretary who himself is
mostly educated at private schools
saying that private schools are great is
to be expected because he's a
millionaire and he's helping to run the
country and if i had you know that kind
of uh life i would probably think that
that was a great path that everyone
should be taking as well interestingly
further in the deemed sahara does talk
about trying to raise standards in state
schools to get them to match some of the
standards in the private schools but of
course part of the issue there is that
private schools have an average funding
of thirteen and a half thousand pounds
ahead and state schools get about seven
so we must be enough they don't have to
say we must leave it that i'm afraid we
have run out of time susie and jake
thank you so much we'll be seeing more
of you in the next town